ca di quella [ __ ] wrecking ball
questo speriamo non ci sia mai le
macchie cazzo mi sembra roba tipo
cazzo la tua chiave hai raccolto cuore
ecco puntano made in uk e un sexy
dunaway
stia parlando arabo cosa del genere
quindi va poco sui modelli bambini che
giocano a pallone di fuori e mi rompono
la finestra si si si poi vai vai se
[Musica]
allora facciamo così io ti chiudo la
porta in faccia al mio treno voglio
vederti più 123 libia salvagente
conquisteremo il mondo ragazzi era cosa
no no fermo ok allora guardate allo
specchio che cazzo sta facendo
camera
si no
ok
[Musica]
quante cazzo di volte ti ho detto di non
usare i petardi in casa
[Musica]
77 gente si cazzo
sono sicuro di essere nel bagno delle
ragazze perché qualcuno ha qui aveva il
suo periodo mi sa perché sono un po
tante le chiazze di sangue comunque
dobbiamo andare sono in mezzo la cosa
oddio due miti gira ma non così
probabilmente rosicare qualcos'altro che
non ho visto no perché succede tutto
così ragazzino più
semplice come che faccio passato il
coltello non trovo il tasto mondo anna
non volevo mostrarvi il coltello ma se
non già le mani di merda non è colpa mia
perché porti anche snai open cunnigham
star so se qualcuno interporranno è
morto subito senza neanche prendere una
moneta sodomizzata no mi ha [ __ ]
mia.com [ __ ]
ragazzino ma questo è chiama sud la rai
non è ancora non è ancora il momento
anche l'udc al momento e tette sono
ingombranti mattino che ti piace sto
abbraccio sexy quasi dolore
macché camminata da minchiona aveva 9
mia moglie dea eccola qui perfetto
ciao amore lo so lo so che mi ami
profondamente anche io perdo la testa
per te devo ok ok frutto stronzo
assaggia il mio culo che è curata in
faccia di quelle potenti ragazzi c'è
scritto uscita io vado dove c'è scritto
uscita perché sono un genio e sono
sicuro ma non si ragazzi ma c'è qualcosa
che non quadra
siamo con justin bieber
devo prendere il tasto giu anna dove
mezzo ragazzi cosa cazzo stoffa c'è
[Musica]
appurato che non lo sa che superman al
100 per c'è mica come l'ho preso
[Musica]
o si sta ingrossando il frigo oppure sia
accorto che qualcosa non va devo cercare
di passargli dietro senza che lui se ne
accorga tipo ok alla ragazza assetto di
guerra
ma cos'è ok ok perfetto allora siamo
partiti male 636 your hand che cazzo se
devo trovare che si sono morto va beh
chi se ne frega la pole a ma prendi la
ragazzi non ce la faremo mai impossibile
io ci rinuncia che cazzo ha parlato sono
qui vedi qui qui dove sono un uomo
cratus ma vecchio ragazzi che questo ti
che bello che tra l'altro la gara è
fantastico io lo amo reso noto che cazzo
è buongiorno sa che chi è che è un po
magro non so come cazzo abbiamo fatto
nell'angolo in alto a sinistra dello
schermo possiamo notare un esemplare di
fa vj alquanto sorpreso ma quanto mai
potrà durare funzione la mossa
incredibile ancora lui ancora lui ancora
lui
[Applauso]
[Musica]
avendo anche che qui siamo straconi di
frutta io una mela tu hai due pere e ci
siamo ragazzi più o meno non si possono
prendere le chiavi fantastico di punto
al sesso scarichi a strozzo dai giochi
giu dello scarto che facciamo finta di
niente nello scarico lo scarico non è
sicuro o intasato un processo ragazzi se
volete scappare di casa non mettetevi
nel sesso perché succede questo non
farlo alzare troppo la matrix non
schiaccia la bligh il manubrio ma in
cambio togliti il volante mio perché
capo togliti da il cazzo sì ho chiesto
dove dov'è andato domandato ho perso
[ __ ] fa un rumore stranissimo tipo
non si sa come e cosa ma quindi sei
bravo se non nuvole o fornisce le sfide
le battaglie vogliamo battaglia per poi
se ok non fa niente buongiorno diamond
avevo neanche vista ma forse è meglio
che non la vedevo sarà finalmente cazzo
oca gatto una testa c'è minima mia
allora
esiste il cazzo di campanello non so se
qualcuno te l'ha spiegato mi sono il
cast cazzo aiuto amare amare prendi
prendi una pala cazzo mi sono incastrati
tra l'altro ho fatto un canestro al
primo tiro che mi è venuto da dio se non
sono anche io come ho fatto
ok cielo quasi troppo lungo baia di
fai e ti puoi vedere che c'è ancora ci
sai fare mi chiamino di una questo nome
non si ricorda neanche ma che cazzo me
l'ho fatto
tanto attento e tanta tanta tanta tanta
tanta tanta tanta tanta star trek
certamente 7 va avanti ed i ci sono ed i
bond della madonna si è fatto malissimo
[Musica]
ma posso guardarti hai paura e se io ti
infila sì questa nel culo a vanno mai
fatto ragazzi coniglio dice volpe che
c'è chi abbia che evoluzione di merda
premie personale all'olio di mozart
posso posso dilettarmi queste cose
fantastiche mian canada
tratto cosa fa quello gioca a calcio con
la testa di nonno ciak
crediamo senti ti andrebbe un po di
schweppes sono io e te
mai visto bastardo